Senator Chuck Schumer ready to accuse
Republicans of a cover-up it's another
huge week on Capitol Hill House
Democrats are preparing a historic vote
on impeachment and then over in the
Senate Chuck Schumer says a trial won't
be fair unless Republicans give in to
his demands on witnesses other Democrats
are ramping up the rhetoric even further
claiming that if President Trump is not
impeached the 2020 election itself could
be compromised we cannot take the risk
that the next election will be corrupted
through foreign interference solicited
by the president which which is clearly
trying to do he withheld hundreds of
millions of dollars to coerce an ally
betray our national security and try to
cheat in the next election if the Senate
Republican majority refuses to
discipline him through impeachment he
will be unbounded and I am gravely
concerned about what else he might do
between now and the 2020 election and
House Democrat Jeff bandru feeling the
wrath of his own party it comes after
Ben Drew said he is becoming a
Republican because of impeachment watch
what he's reacting to is a public
polling that shows he can't get redone
they turn and go to be a Republican it's
kind of strange it's kind of you know
I've heard rats jumping off a sinking
ship but very few of them jump onto a
sinking ship the lowest thing that there
is in the Congress is somebody in the
minority side who was a traitor to the
majority Jessie I was thinking today
speaker Pelosi was quite reluctant to do
impeachment and I think that she she
could read the political tea leaves and
it's turning out that she was right and
her instincts initially were right but
now Chuck Schumer has to deal with this
in the Senate and he is suggesting that
Mitch McConnell would be involved in a
cover-up if they don't do what they want
yeah do what I say or else you're guilty
of a cover-up who cares what Chuck wants
he lost he's a hypocrite they've been so
ruthless this whole time we're not going
to bend over backwards after they've
treated the Republicans so unfairly the
whole thing to say that Trump has rigged
past election in his rigging future
election that is a lie told by losers
they can't win so they have to spin
these are now election birthers any time
Republican wins an election it's some
vast Republican Russian conspiracy the
Republicans haven't even begun a Senate
trial and they're being accused of
rigging it but the Republicans should
ask Democrats had a rig stuff because
the Democrats are pretty good at it
Hillary rigged the primary against
Bernie she tried to rig the general
against Trump by paying for foreign
interference in an election with the
dossier the witch-hunt was rigged
seventeen liberal lawyers I believe the
midterms are rigged because Muller knows
there's no collusion but he lets the
dark cloud of Russia hang over that
election and then they rigged this
hearing in the dark by a whistleblower
shift colluding it's ridiculous and I
brought charts Dana and I've chatted and
graphs I'd like to share because I know
that's the only thing one listens to 538
a guy named Nate Silver liberals trust
him this guy's supposedly legit to you
his approval rating the president at
forty four percent and that's a
percentage higher than when this whole
impeachment thing started and higher
than Barack Obama's was at this term in
his presidency impeachment nationally
for the first time is under water and
cool according to the Real Clear
Politics average which I have right here
and then my favorite chart this and I've
been saying this for a long time the
people don't care about impeachment they
care about football these are the
searches in search engines in
Pennsylvania battleground state the last
month everyone's searching for the
Eagles and the Steelers no one is
searching for impeachment you do that
for any look you can plug in anything in
there
I didn't plug in I just copied it from
someone else what do you think about
Nadler who did the Judiciary Committee
saying that Schiff is correct president
Trump's campaign research into Biden is
a total threat to the twenty twenty
eleven
no it's it's the language right
cover-ups traitors it's it's again it
reveals the Democrats constant like love
of overreach and exaggeration and it
always without fail results in an over
correct correction right if you look at
the Tea Party if you look at 2016 if you
look at Covington if you look at
Cavanaugh the Dems are the Masters of
overkill it always blows up in their
face even if you if you look at like the
DA say it's like a dye pack
remember the dye packs I got like robbed
the bank they put it into the bag of
money and then they get home and they
open it up and it explodes dossier like
almost everything in the democratic
political life is a dye pack they think
that they got all the money that they
get home and it blows up in their face
but I'm a nice person Dana I want to
give them advice okay I think that they
should change the narrative and let go
of the outrage speak I think that we
have been Greta thundered to death for
the lab well before she was born this
has been going on for years and we're
guilty of it the left and right abort
are on both guilty of outrage speak but
I think we're realizing the end of it
when people are noticing that the louder
the noise is in the media the quieter
reality is yeah I mean you can't get
much better than this economy we know
that we have peace it seems like our
troops are coming home people are able
to search for things because they're not
worried about other things so life is
pretty good but the better life gets the
louder it's screecher the media gets and
that's got to tell you that there's
something emotionally wrong with the
with this attitude and I want to help
them because I'm a helper one so the
polling for the Democrats is in great on
they haven't changed anybody's mind like
the Republicans have changed a lot of
minds either but it's definitely not
going in the Democrats direction do you
think that they regret heading down this
road in the first place well let me just
say first and the most important point
that Jesse raised is that as a skins fan
I was in Pennsylvania I would have been
searching for the Eagles too because I
think we should really take a moment
here because one just said skins yeah
nobody didn't say but here's the thing
one when you've got Rudy Giuliani's
still over in the Ukraine you might
think hmm I wonder if he's still trying
to influence the 2020 race the way that
they tried to influence the Russians and
whatever but 2016 race I sounds to me
like huh why would Trump allow Rudy
Giuliani to go back there and give the
opponents the Democrats water because
they think it's rightly that cause I
think it's right it's at all
not hiding anything because they're
stupid okay the second point to be made
to Jessie is this we have a new Fox News
poll that says half the nation half the
nation still favors not only impeaching
still we're moving the same as two
months ago but what you have is I think
you know is the inner pointed out
there's not much of mind changing you go
up or down about four or three points in
either direction but half the country
wants an impeached and half the country
doesn't I don't think a whole lot has
changed on that front but I do think
this that we can agree though I think
everybody this table can agree Fox poll
is a good poll the president doesn't
like it but it's a very good poll I
don't trust any poll I think the people
who are freaking married balance and
other people who are is his name Donald
Trump making front of Nancy Pelosi's
teeth picking on a 16 year old girl
tweeting a wreck this is my point it's
horrific these tweets are horrific you
know they're not you got a Dratch it if
you can Ratchet back your hysteria you
bite people who might actually trust you
when you're critical from one who's
acting in a hysterical manner tweet
they're hilarious
he's acting like Donald Trump since
before he even declared his candidacy
for the Republican nomination you know
when somebody gets loud you know what
that means
they're desperate they sound desperate
and they look desperate to Nadler and
shifts point they don't have a
constitutional right to try and do a
preemptive impeachment to stop and act
that the president might do as The Wall
Street Journal editorial page has
pointed out they're using scare tactics
by the way what Chuck Schumer is doing
he doesn't want to call in these
witnesses and he's actually calling out
Nancy Pelosi for not doing her job by
saying we don't know what evidence these
witnesses would present it might makes
copal Tory or incriminating he's
basically saying Pelosi has fallen down
on what she was supposed to be wondering
about the Schumer having now to deal
with this and scare tactics if they're
gonna use scare tactics
you know what real rats are scary not
the kind that congressman Cohen talks
about terrorism is scary clowns are
scary and people with cold sores that's
scary
Hey look it went away we shook hands oh
can I can I add something to that about
on brought up the polls and there's two
things we have to remind people the
group the people sampled were skewed
towards skew towards Democrats which we
already know is that always happens but
the other thing is people who support
Trump are gonna lie why is it because
we're in a climate where it is unpopular
to voice your opinion so if some
pollsters gonna call me I'm wondering
that pollster is gonna talk about what I
say
I don't know right I don't trust him I
don't trust that's definitely true I
think the dispute towards Democrats is
because they're just look at the big
states that's what most states is where
the president is doing a lot better
exactly I think that's my monologue at
that point that point is actually a very
good one to make